Avoidant attachment disorder.
This is one of the first attachment disorders
that Doctor Erica Commissar
discusses in her recently published book,
being there
why prioritizing motherhood in the first three years matters.
Avoidant attachment disorder
is probably the easiest one for me to discuss
because I already
firsthand know so many people that have this attachment disorder
and you can see it triggle down in every aspect of their life,
especially relationships and dating.
These are the babies
that did not experience enough emotional connection
while they were in their infancy,
become emotionally distant
and avoid connection as a form of coping mechanism
in order to deal with the lack of responsiveness from a caregiver.
So if mom is not being emotionally connected to her baby,
picking her up when baby cries.
Speaking of which, one second back to what I was saying.
As adults, these people appear to be very independent,
self reliant. They struggle with close relationships
and may even be best friend hoppers,
and they greatly suppress their emotions
or even deny them all together.
And lastly, when these avoidant individuals
enter a relationship that becomes somewhat serious
and it's necessary to open up emotionally,
they experience a ridiculous amount of stress.
And in my experience,
a lot of them end up self sabotaging said relationship
because in their eyes,
anything would be better than opening up emotionally
because they were let down so much when they were babies.
Even though it's all subconscious and they don't Really remember it?
Every time they weren't picked up,
when they cried, every time they didn't feel connected to a mom.
Maybe she had postpartum. Maybe she just wasn't there.
They had to go within themselves and create a defense mechanism
and a coping style, which became the avoidant attachment disorder.
Drop a comment below. I guarantee you have dated someone
or known someone with this avoidant attachment disorder.
Sir, you are being so loud.